the commuter was directed by hua Mei
Colette Sarah and stars Liam Neeson in
their fourth collaboration after unknown
non stop and run all night and they
currently have another film a fifth one
in production this is like the new
Martin Scorsese and Robert De Niro of
perfectly acceptable movies Neeson plays
Michael Macaulay a retired ex-cop who is
now working in insurance who commutes on
a train every day to work and he finds
himself in the middle of a sticky
situation when Vera Farmiga introduces
herself and says someone on this train
doesn't belong we'll give you $100,000
to find them and point them out to us
because we need this done and you can
help us and of course with action and
thrillers like this it's never quite as
easy as it seems
and it gets increasingly more difficult
for Neeson to complete this simple task
that at one point in time seemed pretty
easy this movie is really entertaining
and it's a fourth film made by these
guys that I've liked the previous three
are not great movies by any means but
they are entertaining thrillers and
they're fun most of them run all night
probably the least of them but non-stop
in particular definitely have some
issues with implausibility as does the
commuter and you could say this is
non-stop but on a train you could say
that
and there are similarities for sure but
whenever you set a thriller on a moving
vehicle like say 1994 speed which is one
of my favourite action movies and you do
things right you can have a really fun
movie and the commuter understands what
it needs in this film it doesn't
overstay its welcome it doesn't overstep
its boundaries with its plot it just
tries to be an entertaining movie with
characters that you can get behind and
Neeson has this character in this role
down pat the noble everyday guy who just
wants to help his family and some people
who might get in the way who need his
help but the difference here is that
there's a bit of a moral ambiguity to
his character that I appreciated and
that's because the setup for his
character I didn't see revealed in any
trailer of course I only watched one so
maybe later trailers revealed this but
he's having financial difficulties and
so when this is presented to him
as an option this 100 grand to do this
simple thing part of him is thinking
like yeah okay I'll do that even though
he knows that it could result in
someone's harm and so that aspect of his
character I appreciate it because it
wasn't just a guy with special skills
who wants to save his family the film
raises some interesting questions about
what we would do if we were presented
with that situation and how would we act
and that makes the action set-pieces
that proceeded more entertaining because
yeah it's a big dumb action movie this
is probably my biggest issue with the
film it is very implausible at times
there are things that happen where on
retrospect you think about it and you're
like the timing of that was insane and
if people are orchestrating these events
from afar and calling him and then
telling him to look and see something
happen and it's just like oh boy I don't
quite buy that but the breakneck pace of
this movie and the fact that everyone
involved with it is acting their asses
off and the fact that wah made Colette
Sarah is a pretty damn good director
really save this movie from some rather
implausible parts now I'm a fan of
Neeson and action movies but some of the
action films he has done have had really
bad fight scenes with a lot of shaky-cam
and quick cut editing which most action
fans can't stand myself included this
film has one of the best Neeson fight
scenes I've ever seen it's multiple
takes made to look like one but I found
it riveting in fact there are a lot of
action scenes that are set on this one
small location that benefit from the
fact that it's very claustrophobic and
that closed-in atmosphere that knowledge
that this character doesn't have
anywhere else to go and he just has to
sit there and interview people and try
to figure out a normal way to ask
someone who's a stranger who they are so
he can hopefully find out who this one
person he's supposed to find is and
seeing him have to wiggle his way
through these conversations was a really
good idea from a thriller perspective
and that's something this film does very
well it takes this character and it puts
them in increasingly more insane
situations where
it's not just a life-threatening
situation there are plenty of action
sequences where you think oh he's gonna
get his head cut off or something's
gonna happen or the trains gonna blow up
or whatever but there's a lot of
sequences of incredible awkwardness
where he has to talk to people and try
to figure out like who are you exactly
and not come off weird because a lot of
them are young women and so he has to
traverse that as well and figure out how
do I talk to this girl and not creep her
out and despite some of the
impossibility zuv the plot that is good
character work in a very fun way to make
your lead character endearing because
you feel for the guy and you want to see
him do the right thing
but you also recognize that there's all
these obstacles in his way and that's
the best way to make a fun thriller and
this is yet another perfectly fine
January movie I have yet to see a
terrible January movie so that's cool
there's some movies still to come out
this year so who knows what's gonna
happen there I'm afraid as far as
modern-day collaborations between actors
and directors go this is one of my
favorites are they making very similar
films that are watchable and
entertaining and don't really challenge
the medium or give us anything new to
think about sure but I'll say it again
they're watchable and entertaining and
Vera Farmiga and Patrick Wilson are both
in this movie maybe it's like a bizarre
spin-off of the conjuring universe I'm
gonna give the commuter a B if you like
a good dispensable thriller that reminds
you of the old nineties action movies
definitely go check out the commuter
it's fun guys thank you so much as
always for watching and if you like this
you can click right here and get stuck
mine eyes
[Music]